we've had as you've had cameras up and
down the country haven't we Tom um in
West London March reaction did you hear
it
yeah I mean it was a bit of a cacophony
wasn't it a bit of a surprise because it
did come early so people here looking at
their phones ask everyone they're
finishing their Sunday lunches what they
thought of it guys when that alarm went
off were you expecting it was that how
you think it was going to be
it didn't go off your thing go off yes
you didn't get one no I came later some
of us came before us so uh yeah and was
it loud was it quieter than expected not
loud enough for an emergency and that
situation maybe next time they can do it
okay come over here guys um was it as
you expected did you know it was going
to happen
haven't been selected some have been
left behind as it were yeah and did you
know ahead I mean there was some sort of
briefing around it because it's the
first time it's been used did you all
know it was going to happen is it
something that the message you got
through some did I didn't personally
about it but through people at work not
through any sort of notifications I
thought the wording was a bit extreme
any more sense well I think severe alert
when it's a test is a little bit far
yeah but not not too much of an
interruption to a Sunday afternoon
a good way good way to finish a good
lunch by the legs and things thanks very
much guys so yeah a bit of a mixed
reaction lots of people not getting into
that and that's interesting because when
you think about what this is everyone in
the country well 88 of people has a
smartphone so there's never really been
so many people in the UK looking at the
same thing at the same time that's if
everyone got that message of course have
you been talking about the government
says that is important for safety in
terms of warning of a terrorist threat
it can be more geographically located
others pointing out there's probably
fears around privacy but it's got a very
mixed reaction here in Southwest London
okay for now Tom thank you very much Tom
Tasha